well let's talk to the leader of the
labour party sakia stamina who joins us
now good to see you this morning
are we meeting our responsibilities as a
nation when it comes to
to the pandemic well uh across the world
obviously this huge concern particularly
in
india and i think that the more we can
do um
to assist india the better and i know
the government is already taking steps
in that direction and i urge them um to
increase that where they can it's got to
be a global
response but i think it is a reminder
that notwithstanding the
successful rollout of the vaccine here
we won't be
through this truly through this um until
across the world we've got the virus
completely under control i think
many many people will be distressed
looking at the situation
currently in india can we talk about the
the elections this we've got local
elections we've got a by-election i mean
the labour party has been accused of
being well you know
a little bit policy light going into
these elections
well what we've said is there should be
400 000
new jobs created bringing forward
initiatives
due to the next five years in loco
carbon
areas we've said there should be a
guarantee for young people that if young
people have been out of work
for six months um or so they should be
in education they should be in training
or they should have a job
guarantee we said we want more police
officers on the
beat on the streets not behind desks
and we'd be very clear about bringing
down anti-social behavior and
a fair reward for those on the front
line particularly the nhs
now they've been our priorities and um
my job as leader of the labor party is
to make it absolutely clear
that i've got a burning desire to build
a better
future for our country and that thursday
is the
opportunity the first opportunity to
take a step towards that
and to demonstrate that the priorities
of the labour party that i
lead are the priorities of the british
public
but if those priorities are ones that
resonate with the british public then
the polls must make just some
disappointing reading for you
i mean you know after the obviously
there's a scandal
surrounding number 10 at the moment uh
we've got
this huge recession you know the biggest
most aggressive recession facing the g7
because of the
the pandemic which you know is
understandable
uh and yet you still are trading in the
polls i mean
quite significantly in some places well
you know there's no getting away from
the fact
that we lost the last general election
in december 2019
very badly the worst loss we've had
since 1935
and my job as leader of late party is to
rebuild our party
reconnect with the public rebuild trust
that will take
time but the most important thing
is that i make it clear that i
understand
that every vote has to be earned it's
why i've been across the united kingdom
talking to people in different
communities been in hartlepool
three times talking um about the jobs of
the future
things that really matter but um you
know i know we've got to earn every vote
i know that we've got to rebuild out of
that devastating loss in 2019.
it's a mountain decline but we're
climbing it i mean
forgive me though i mean when you talk
about hartlepool that there is one pole
out this wild message is it's one poll
that we've seen that's that's got labour
nine points down
at the moment yeah i've been in
hartlepool
three times we're having thousands of
conversations
with voters in hartlepool with the teams
that we've got there
there is a positive response but we've
got to build on that we've got to earn
every vote
in hartlepool and you know in hartlepool
the things that people have
um said to me matter most of them
there's a nuclear power plant in
hartlepool coming to the end of its
natural life and everybody wants to know
what's the next generation of jobs there
there's
750 hartlepool jobs tied up in that
power station
i was at liberty steel on saturday
morning
250 people they're really worried still
workers worried about
their jobs and that is what matters most
in hartley paul it's why hartley paul
needs a powerful labor voice
to stick up for those jobs and stick up
for the next generation yeah well again
it goes back to the question if that's
what matters most and and you think
that's what labour can deliver then why
are people
not flocking to the labor party
according to the latest polls i mean
it begs the question as to whether you
have pitched things in the right way in
the run-up to this you've
you've gone all out on the sleaze
allegations
has that been the right approach well
we've put first and foremost actually
jobs
um the nhs frontline and getting crime
under control and dealing with
anti-social behaviour they're our
priorities
of course uh we have
shone a torch on the sleeves because
what we've seen recently is
clear evidence that those at the top of
government feel that the rules just
don't apply to them
whether that's contracts on whatsapp
groups whether it's privilege
access um or whether it's refurbishment
of flats a general sense that there's
one rule for them and another rule for
everybody else and coming out of the
pandemic
when people have really struggled for a
year or more
the idea that somehow it's priced in
that that's how
the government behaves i think he's
completely completely wrong
and yet you know you're a year into the
job
you know you've got a lifelong labor
voter down in was it bristol or bath
you're throwing you out of his pub
saying
you know you'd let him down as labour
leader that i mean that's a
it's a big obstacle to overcome you
don't seem to be managing it at the
moment
since you put that example to me let's
just be clear about
what the argument was about that
landlord
believed that um only old people
were dying in the virus and therefore
there was no need for a lockdown no need
for
restrictions um having
particularly since my wife works in the
hospital having seen what was happening
at the height of the pandemic with over
a thousand people dying every day i
profoundly
disagree with that now he's entitled to
his view of course he is
i am never going to agree with the view
that we didn't need a lockdown and that
the virus is only
killing old people i'm sorry i don't
you're quoted in the times this morning
as saying you will take
full responsibility for these election
results when we get to sift through them
friday morning
if you don't do well if you don't take
hartley pool if you don't make
significant inroads in the local
elections does that mean you're gonna go
well look i do take full responsibility
for these election
results i take full responsibility for
everything that the labour party does
under my
leadership just as i took full
responsibility for
everything the crown prosecution service
did when i was director of public
prosecution
that is what leadership is about i am
um clear that my job as leader of labour
party is to rebuild
the labour party from where we were in
december 2019 with the worst result
since 1935 into a position where we can
win the next general election
that is a mountain to climb we are
climbing um that mountain
my job is to make it clear that the
priorities of the labour party under my
leadership
are the priorities of the british people
that we will face
forgive me for jumping in i know we're
really tight for time but if you say
you're taking responsibility what does
that mean
if it doesn't work out the way you want
by friday morning
we are fighting for every vote into this
election
on thursday earning every vote that's
why i'm out
pretty well every hour of daylight
fighting for those votes alongside the
team that we've got we'll go into
thursday with a very positive
message about the change that we want to
make for our country
for the better and indicating that this
is the first step
towards that change the job of
rebuilding the labour party
was never going to be completed in a
year or so i don't think anybody
realistically
bought that but these are a very very
important set of elections for us